wo ist dein weg
du hast sie gebunden
wo war das denn bergstraße worden ist
dann einfach sorgt der straße beim
großen haus
es ist ein cooles t shirt und du hast
tonne mützen danke
sechs kerne mit sieben ja sogar welche
farbe man am liebsten ist mein
lieblingsfach
er stimmt was die mich viele grüne
sachen das t shirt ist grün
dieses hemd ist grün und dieses jahr aus
dann waren wir erst in welchem film am
die sind aber hier nein das ist nicht
mal warme pullover ist ein sonst alister
per handy
mannheim ich hatte ein buntes hin das
ist auch weg das war mein ich habe eine
idee wir gehen in die stadt und die
kochs ein neues hemd und einen warmen
pullover
hast du lust weiß wie man günstig
einkaufen kann
ich habe auch nicht viel geld